-Here with the TV debut of
her new song, "Want Want,"
from her upcoming album,
"Surrender,"
give it up for Maggie Rogers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ If you want-want what you
want-want, then you want it ♪
♪♪
♪ You're better than the men I
knew when we were in a band ♪
♪ And you wouldn't flinch and
wouldn't make a move ♪
♪ Try to forget the rest as I
watch you get undressed ♪
♪ Pray to God this won't be
a mess ♪
♪ And I keep runnin' away ♪
♪ But when I leave,
you pull me in again ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
♪ Here we go ♪
♪ I hold my breath
and count the times ♪
♪ I walked my feet up
to the line ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
♪ We both know ♪
♪ If you want-want what you
want-want, then you want it ♪
♪ Can't hide what you desire
once you're on it ♪
♪ Can't fake what you can't
break up with ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
♪ If you understand that a few
years won't erase it ♪
♪ Might die if you can't live
just to taste it ♪
♪ Want-want what you want-want,
then you want it ♪
♪ And I want you ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Can we take this slow? ♪
♪ Everybody's always known ♪
♪ But I didn't want to admit ♪
♪ That when we're cheek to
cheek, I feel it in my teeth ♪
♪ And it's too good to resist ♪
♪ And I keep runnin' away ♪
♪ But when I leave,
you pull me in again ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
♪ We both know ♪
♪ -If you want-want what you
want-want, then you want it ♪
♪ Can't hide what you desire
once you're on it ♪
♪ Can't fake what you can't
break up with ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
-♪ If you understand that a few
years won't erase it ♪
-♪ Might die if you can't live
just to taste it ♪
♪ Want-want what you want-want,
then you want it ♪
-[ Vocalizes ]
-♪ Want-want what you want-want,
then you want it ♪
♪ Can't hide what you desire
once you're on it ♪
♪ Can't fake what you can't
break up with ♪
♪ Oh-ohhh ♪
-[ Vocalizes ]
-♪ If you understand that a few
years won't erase it ♪
♪ Might die if you can't live
just to taste it ♪
♪ Want-want what you want-want,
then you want it ♪
-♪ Oh, and if you got a moment,
I want-want it ♪
♪ Want-want-want it, want it ♪
♪ And if you got another hour,
I want all of it ♪
♪ Don't wanna wait another
moment, I want-want it ♪
♪ Want-want-want it, want it ♪
♪ Don't wanna wait another hour,
I want all of it ♪
♪ Want-want, want ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]